stranger things is currently on Netflix
all eight episodes are uploaded right
now for season 1 it was created by the
duffer brothers and tells the story of a
young boy named will buyers who
disappears and his mother a police chief
and his group of friends who are
investigating his disappearance trying
to figure out what happened and some
strange otherworldly forces just might
be involved in some way so I'm gonna
keep this review mostly spoiler free
because I have friends who haven't
watched it yet and I'm sure some of you
guys haven't seen it yet so I'm going to
be vague about plot details and I'll
just leave it at that let's talk about
the quality of this show if you are well
versed in cinema of the 1980s or
literature of the 1980s then it's very
clear to you that this TV show is very
much so inspired by Stephen King's early
novels and Steven Spielberg's early
films and if you are a fan of these
things which I just so happened to be
and that's obviously going to be a plus
for you I love this style of this show
it's an instant hook for me it very much
so feels like a movie that Spielberg
would have directed in the 80s and that
Stephen King would have written the
screenplay for so instantaneously I'm
hooked by the style and appeal of this
show just on the way it's helmed it's
obvious that the duffer brothers are
huge fans of this source material
because everything from the opening logo
which looks just like Stephen King's
font for his earliest books to many plot
elements sharing very similar themes to
Spielberg's movies as well as Stephen
King's books it's clear that these guys
like this stuff so part of me right
there obviously it's like yes I like
that that that's good I like the way
that feels you're touching the right
places everything's good yes but in the
long run we know that style can only get
you so far in regards to emotional
investment and this show has got to have
some substance and some weight behind it
to make us actually care and want to
watch more and it does the main hook of
this show is the disappearance of this
boy
the mother trying to search for him
played by Winona Ryder very well I might
add a police chief played by David
Harbor who slowly gets more obsessed
with various possibilities as he
investigates this boy's disappearance
with a local government agency that just
might be involved in some way the
downward spiral of his character in this
show for me was one of the biggest hooks
I thought Harbor was really
really good in this show it was cool to
see his character progress and change so
much in just eight episodes I really dug
his character also fantastic is the
three kids who are now searching for
their best friend
these kids were absolute gold they were
so funny
so likable and my favorite part of these
characters is that they actually talk
like kids
one of the biggest downfalls in regards
to child actors and child performances
for movies and TV is that adults are
writing this dialogue and sometimes it's
hard for an adult to put himself in the
mind of a child
and write dialogue that a kid would
actually say in this show the kids
dialogue feels like things that a kid
would say there are times where you know
conversations just end maybe there isn't
a big arc or a big important emotional
moment for a kid sometimes the kid will
just be like who cares whatever and
that'll be the end of the conversation
because kids are like that and there's
also no attempt to censor these kids
they're going to curse they're going to
say things like that and it works that
way because it feels like kids also the
older brother of will Byers played by
Charlie Heaton was excellent in this
show because he has a very reserved
character his character is kind of the
loner he's the outsider a lot of people
look down on him
and he finds himself constantly having
to explain himself to other people for
his actions as well as why not a writer
who goes kind of insane at least in the
eyes of most people because she's trying
all these different ways to contact her
son because to her it's working there's
also this weird entity that's going
around and only a few people are seeing
it and so obviously in this small town
where nothing bad ever happens most
people look at these people like yeah
you're nuts and so there's also that
element where you want these characters
to be proven right you want them to get
their moment where they're like see this
is what I've been saying it's it's real
it got to listen to me this is
happening and whenever you have that
momentum built up within a show or a
movie it makes you want to watch more
because you want to see that justice
given to these characters but I've been
saving this character for last because
she is by far the best part of this show
the character of 11 a young girl with a
shaved head who arrives who doesn't say
much who clearly has a very damaged past
we learned through flashbacks that
experiments were done to her in the past
she also possesses telekinesis this is
easily the most intriguing character in
the show played by Milly Bobby Brown and
this girl was fan-freaking-tastic she
was so excellent in the show this is
like an adult performance squeezed into
a little girl's body she was so so real
there was never a scene where I felt
like she broke character there was never
a moment where I felt like she wasn't
being completely real
she was easily the best and most
compelling character in the show and her
performance is M worthy I mean she is so
damn good in this show but in regards to
the group of boys that are searching for
their friend my favorite character was
easily dustin this kid was so funny he
was so likable and what I loved about
these guys was their tight-knit
friendship they have their own little
code almost and it was just it was great
I do have one major problem with this
show and it's sort of a gray area
because I've already discussed my love
for the omage is to various films and
books from my childhood that I've
appreciated my whole life but paying
homage to something is walking a very
difficult tightrope because you can come
off very easily as not doing anything
new and just sort of recreating things
that you already love and copying off of
things there are moments in this show
that are exactly like et3 kids hiding
someone in their basement this time it's
a girl that has weird powers in et with
three kids hiding an alien that has
weird powers there's a scene in this
show where they're on their bicycles and
the girls on the bike with them and
they're fleeing from the government
Matthew Modine 'he's character in this
show might as well be the keys character
from ET except in this show his intent
is far more evil there are just a lot of
things where you're like man that really
is exactly like firestarter written by
Stephen King or man that is really like
Carey or man that's really like et and
you just see all these connections and
it's like I love the attributing it but
man that's really like that so like I
said it's a difficult tightrope and I
would say the show mostly succeeds but
it did bug me after a while just how
many tributes there were and I'm very
excited to see another season I hope
that in season two
it's a little more original I like the
way to season concluded but I do want to
see more and I hope that certain things
are explained a little more because
there's a lot of questions which is to
be expected
in a show so I can't really downgrade it
for that because I'm assuming that some
of these unanswered questions how
various things came to be and what was
actually going on will be answered in
other seasons and hopefully we get a
season 2 that being said I had a great
time watching stranger things I would
recommend it and I'm going to give it an
a - it's on Netflix right now it's only
8 episodes I do highly recommend
checking it out also I want to give a
big thank you to all the people who did
purchase my book it's currently
available on Amazon and Barnes & Noble
across the country it means a great deal
to me that you guys have shown so much
love and support for something I worked
on and man I seriously just want to say
thank you you guys are the best I have a
link on my home page on my youtube
channel for that book if you'd like to
check it out it's available on eBook or
in print form and like I said at Barnes
& Noble across the country thank you so
much guys for checking out my book it
really means the world to me you guys
are the best thank you so much for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck menage
Oh